hey guys yeah of course halloween is
over but we still have the uh dia de los
muertos festival that goes all the way
until tomorrow so we're going to bring
in councilman isaac barron our good
friend of ours so tell us a little bit
more about the folks that don't know
what dia de los muertos is tell us about
what it is well it's actually a very
ancient tradition
before columbus ever made it and what's
happened is we have a christian
tradition mixing with a native american
tradition to make something new the la
muertos is a day that's actually uh well
actually two days today and tomorrow
yeah but it's used as a celebration of
life you're not celebrating death you're
actually celebrating life and by doing
so um many people will choose to
celebrate by making an altar which is
kind of like a shrine dedicated to the
memory of someone maybe from your family
or someone that you know who's passed
away now tell us about this young lady
over here we want to show this alter
specifically because she was a rancho
high school teacher correct yeah she was
one of my colleagues i missed dixie ask
axed and of course mr thomas plesh they
were both teachers educators beloved uh
teachers and of course uh mr mr pletch
was a coach coach pletch my colleagues
they were beloved and they passed away
last year
very untimely deaths
but
when it was decided when we were looking
for someone to to honor from our school
it was a no-brainer for us to pick these
two very well-respected educators and of
course we know that with a cove and
everything one one institution that's
been really overloaded sometimes is
education so i think it's very fitting
all right councilman pedro thank you so
much i know you you got an event you got
to get to so get out of here yeah i know
you gotta
always oh we're always taking up your
time you're always spending time with us
we appreciate that okay guys so of
course this event goes all the way
through the bar you heard councilman
veron it's not just today it goes all
the way through tomorrow too we're at
the uh
the um dondero cultural multicultural
center down here on pecos mcleod and d.i
and it's a big party down here of course
you can see we've got a lot of the stage
now open this started at five o'clock
goes all the way to nine o'clock tonight
that goes also for tomorrow too if you
think about where you should go for
dinner hey they've got dinner here too
they got plenty of food plenty of
shopping down here too to check out dia
de los muertos like we said goes all the
way through tomorrow
as a celebration of life not morning but
a celebration of life reporting live
down here at the cultural center ted
florendale live local now we'll send it
back to you